[Music]
the streets of Los Angeles today were
filled with striking teachers you're
asking for smaller class sizes and a pay
raise over 30,000 public school teachers
nurses counselors and librarians went on
strike last week in Los Angeles for the
first time in nearly 30 years driving
the protest word union demands for
higher salaries smaller class sizes and
more funding for school nurses and
counselors district administrators said
those demands would hasten the system's
descent into insolvency it's not about
the money for us our schools are
dramatically underserved we don't want
to privatize public education while
teacher salaries haven't increased much
an inflation adjusted terms since the
1990s total teacher compensation has
soared because of ballooning health care
and retirement contributions there's a
growing disconnect between what teachers
see in their paychecks and what their
employers are actually paying for their
services we spoke to chad aldeman editor
a teacher pensions org and a senior
associate partner at bellwether
education partners to discuss what's
really driving school budgets to the
brink teachers are getting paid kind of
the same when you adjust for inflation
but the cost to the districts for
teachers have gotta massively what's
going on there they're spending more
money but the teachers aren't getting it
where's it go the big driving factor is
that benefits are eating up a larger and
larger share of compensation this is
true across the economy but in teachers
it's more extreme than other sectors and
that's due to both fast rising health
care retiree health care benefits and
pensions according to census data Los
Angeles has increased its overall
education spending over 55 percent since
2001 with most of that increase going to
employee benefits Los Angeles is
projected to spend more than half of the
entire city budget just on teachers
retirement and health care by the 2030
one school year who's kind of pushing
things into the
fringe benefit or you know or benefits
side of things I mean in this case the
district and the Union have negotiated
health benefits the retiree health
benefits over time and so it's hard to
say what average teachers want I think
if you asked a teacher today
would you prefer a dollar and base
salary or a dollar and benefit spending
they definitely prefer the dollar and
base salary because they can use it on
things like their mortgage or childcare
or taking a vacation or whatever it is
that's most pressing in their life at
that moment and there's lots of evidence
that workers don't value benefits the
same as they cost and so every dollar
the district is pumping into benefits
means that they're not getting a dollar
and value in terms of employee enjoyment
or usefulness but I guess they can also
they don't have to pay it immediately
right that's another factor is that the
districts can make a promise that then
they don't have to fully front-load pay
as they accrue that's a big factor in
particularly in the retiree health
benefits for a long time the actuarial
rules said that districts don't have to
count what the promises they may will
cost in the future and so they were only
counting how much they were paying in
that given year the counting rules
changed recently and so districts like
la are starting to realize how much
they've actually promised and it's a big
amount a big dollar number after six
days the teachers union in the city came
to a tentative agreement on raises and
class size however by agreeing to boost
salaries without reducing what it spends
on benefits Los Angeles has made its
fiscal problems even worse the district
is bleeding so much money that its
projected to go bankrupt by the decade
which would lead to a state takeover and
possible layoffs when you see striking
teachers their emotional kids who are
not going to school get emotional
parents get really emotional about this
kind of stuff because it's partly they
don't want their kid to be in a class
that has 50 other kids in it they want
resources like music teachers are
teachers school nurses on campus how do
you explain to them that if that the
status quo is not going to work anymore
this it's just not sustainable yeah I
mean this is a tough issue and I would
prefer to pay teachers more I think that
they do one of the most important jobs
society the problem is we just have
these structural barriers in place to
helping pay them more and some of the
benefits that the district has signed on
to overtime has forced them into very
difficult choices so the retiree health
benefits for example are costing the
district right now about ten to twelve
thousand dollars per teacher and those
costs are expected to double within nine
years and triple within 15 years and so
just over time the district is gonna
have less and less discretionary dollars
to go to things like librarians or field
trips or hiring more teachers or
lowering class sizes and so that there's
structural issues at play that are
forcing the district to make tough
choices a sticking point in the
negotiations between the district and
the teachers union was the city's
growing number of charter schools where
most teachers didn't participate in the
strike since 2012 K through 12
enrollment at district schools has
fallen by almost a hundred thousand
students while enrollment at independent
charter schools has grown by thirty-four
thousand students because funding for
schools is tied to the number of
students who attend striking teachers
say charters are a drain on their
resources and that they're destroying
Union jobs the strikers were asking for
a cap on charter schools and more
regulation of them students and there's
no regulations on them they can pop up
at any point so if teachers are in a
strike
well charters can say hey here's another
option but is this really the case so
LAUSD had been losing enrollment for the
last couple decades and the charters are
part of that reason but not the only
reason students are leaving to go to
other public school districts or private
schools as well and so the charters are
part of that and what that does by
losing enrollment means that any fixed
cost the district is carrying like
facilities or benefit costs a law firm
are made it eat up higher and higher
share of the remaining budget our
charter schools in general which are you
know publicly funded schools that get a
percentage of the typical per student
amount that a traditional school
residential assignment school gets but
they're freed up from various rules are
they better at
with compensation and benefits packages
that are sustainable yes in general so
there's some states that require their
charter schools to participate in the
state pension plan so they don't behalf
of states that have charters require
them to do that and so the charters
don't have any choice about their
retirement plan the other states that
give them choice
it varies and there's different
decisions about sort of the strategies
and who they want to attract and why
they would or not join but there are
different sites types of compensation
systems they do front-load more they do
have more incentives for performance
along the way and they have different
types of retirement plans a lot of times
those are actually better for workers
than the pension plans because of the
front-loading issues and because of some
of the unfunded liability issues as well
it is it also partly portability I mean
if you're doing a defined contribution
plan typically you get to when you move
or you leave a job you get to take that
with you so if you're in a traditional
pension plan and you leave anytime
before you're fully vested or before it
really pays off you're just kind of [ __ ]
out of luck
yeah absolutely and and particularly for
urban teachers who have higher turnover
rates charter school teachers who tend
to be in urban areas that have higher
turnover rates a portable plan makes
much more sense than a plan that relies
on someone staying for their whole
career the LA strike follows a series of
walk outs last spring in states such as
West Virginia Oklahoma Colorado and
Arizona where teachers consistently came
away with big pay increases from state
legislators does the future of public
education look a lot like what's
happening in LA right now I mean we were
coming off a year where there's a lot of
protests got a lot of ink there was a
lot of media driven coverage of teachers
having to work extra jobs this sort of
thing is this the new normal I see two
things they'll happen one is in places
that don't have increases for teachers
there'll be some hostility potentially
some more strikes or some places are
trying to get in front of that so the
Republican governor of Georgia newly
elected governor there
recently announced that he's gonna push
for a $3,000 raise for teachers so
that's not a traditional step for
Republican governor in Georgia but he
promised on the campaign trail to do
that and he sees this as a down payment
and there are other states like that
where the 2018 elections were hot about
they were often discussed about teacher
pay and and school budgets and so I
think we'll see some of that sort of dam
breaking in the near future
[Music]